I love that feeling when it's the
beginning of fall and it's 55 degrees
outside and it's finally cold enough to
wear my favorite winter sweater and
jacket and beanie and gloves and I drink
pumpkin spice lattes to stay warm
but I also love the feeling when it's
the middle of winter and out of nowhere
it's 55 degrees so I leave my parka home
and go outside in my shorts and t-shirt
and feel the warmth of the sun on my
skin and I consider going to the beach
to tan because it's so warm
the temperature is the same but my
reaction to it is vastly different part
of the reason why is that there's more
of a substance in my body in January as
compared to September it's the same
substance that allows kids and teens to
handle the cold weather better than
adults
laughs
when you're hot you sweat when you're
cold you shiver but just before you
start to shiver your body actually does
something else it starts to burn fat not
the fat we usually think of there are
two categories of fat that we like to
think about there's the white fat white
fat is the one that we tend to just
think of as fats it's called White
because it looks white white fat exists
all throughout the body cushioning our
bones and organs that's Dr Aaron cypus
by the way
white fat cells have many functions one
of the most important being that they're
the body's primary energy source every
single day we are using the fuel that's
inside the white fat cells but there's
another type of fat that has a totally
different function Brown fat these cells
are much smaller and because of that
resemble muscle more than fat instead of
one large lipid droplet in a white fat
cell the brow fat cell is one tightly
packed bag of mitochondria this is what
gives it its Brown appearance and if you
remember anything from high school
biology class you know that the
mitochondria are the PowerHouse of the
cell
Brown fat instead of serving as an
energy reserve for organs throughout the
body to burn uses its power to burn
energy on its own and unlike white fat
it's only located in a few tactically
positioned areas it is in the neck the
shoulders in the upper arms it's down
the spine and then some places within
the belly lots of overlap with major
blood vessels because warming the blood
effectively warms the whole body through
a brown fat around the neck vessels
heats up the blood goes to the brain
that's good the brow fat Depots in the
shoulders that blood once it's been
heated by the brow stack goes right very
quickly into the heart and they can get
pumped to the rest of the body and
that's the first line of defense against
the cold if it's not enough to raise the
body temperature sufficiently then the
body Shivers but one of the craziest
things that I learned while researching
this story is that babies can't shiver
when babies are born they do not have
the muscle mass and really craps neither
so much of the coordination with the
brain and the muscle to to shiver
effectively so they need other ways of
generating Heats and brown fat is part
of that babies are born with a lot of
brown fat according to the Cleveland
Clinic about two to five percent of a
baby's body weight is made up of the
stuff it's necessary for our survival
the peak age for brown fat actually
seems to be in the teen years which
explains why a lot of the guys in my
high school wore shorts in the winter
but as we get older our body makes less
of it and this could give us some
insight into why kids seem to run hot
and our parents or grandparents seem to
run cold older people they certainly
have a much less brown fat in terms of
absolute and relative amounts there's
also less muscle which is also important
for generating heat the similarities
between brown fat and muscle don't end
there though if you work your brown fat
out it also increases in volume and the
way you do this is by exposing yourself
to the cold for extended periods of time
as this 2014 study shows look at how
much more Brown fat these men from
Maryland had after a month of exposure
to cold temperatures and look how much
less they had when exposed to warm
temperatures which gives us some insight
into why 55 degrees in the winter can
feel so much warmer than 55 degrees in
the fall Brown fat doesn't just keep you
warm though scientists have figured out
that having more of it correlates the
lower risk of diabetes and heart disease
studying the effects of brown fat using
cold exposure is challenging though One
Challenge is that it's hard to dose coal
how much I gave you this amount of I
mean you know the temperature but it's
hard to know what you're doing and
therefore it's very hard to design a
study where it's reproducible so instead
they're trying to activate Brown fat
with medicine to study how burning it
affects us biologically a medication
called marabagran which is approved to
treat overactive bladder was able to
activate the brown fat in a way that was
very similar to the effectiveness of the
cold explosion there's a lot we still
don't know about Brown fat but we do
know that our bodies use it to adapt to
cold weather and when a kid doesn't want
to put a coat on in the winter it's not
necessarily that they're just stubborn
it might just be because they have a
little more of something in their body
than you do
[Music]
foreign